when you wish upon a star sometimes you
get a dang interesting story
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so ladies patreon sponsored review
time and this time I got commissioned to
take a look at Stardust now this is the
film 2007 I believe film based off the
Neil Gaiman book of the same name and I
get to do something that I don't need to
do that often and actually draw
comparisons between the book and the
movie cuz I read the book I think this
actually might might have been one of
the few times that I've read the book
before I saw the movie that happens very
rarely I've talked about why I don't I
try not to do that deliberately but like
sometimes a book that I have already
read gets made into a movie and that was
the case here now I'd wanted to like
continue to stretch myself a little bit
in terms the editing get fancy use clips
to illustrate things except I fired it
up at the beginning was the Paramount
logo so there aren't gonna be any clips
actually there aren't gonna be any
images at all because if you're new
around these parts paramount are the
biggest jerks when it comes to copyright
the most unreasonable and yeah I'm not
gonna give you a history of my problems
with them just remember around here we
say [ __ ] paramount but I'm not gonna
hold that against the movie because you
know sometimes good movies get stuck
with jackass distributors
anyways so Stardust is is a film that
okay how do we how do we describe this
thing what I would say is it it's a
modern take on a fairy tale it I say
modern it's not like set in modern day
but it's a sort of a reinterpretation on
the fairy tale stylings by way of sort
of swashbuckling adventure tonally I
would compare it to the Princess Bride I
don't want to over stress that
comparison though because it is sort of
going things about going about things in
a bit of a different way and I don't
want to like force people to like say
they prefer one or the other but I think
overall tone vibe feel of the thing is
reminiscent of the Princess Bride and
actually the director Matthew Vaughn
cited that as an inspiration and that
honestly aside from a couple of things
that we'll talk about
later is the major difference between
the book and the movie the book is a
fairy tale for adults in a bit more of
an adult sense Wow I wouldn't say that
the book is excessively graphic it is
pretty blunt when it comes to things
like violence death sexual content and
so forth whereas the movie is pg-13 so
that stuff is there we just don't we
don't see it in all of its juicy details
I wish I'd picked a different word ah
I'm sorry but that's the major
difference aside from a couple of
logistical story differences then
obviously a lot of stuff got cut because
the the book I mean that's that I don't
even have to justify that a novel always
has stuff cut into a movie the only way
you don't get anything cut as if you
make a frigging miniseries or a
long-running TV show and even then stuff
usually still gets cut so the plot is
primarily about a character named
Tristan thorn who's played by Charlie
Cox better known these days as Matt
Murdock or daredevil in the Netflix
daredevil series and it's actually kind
of really fun watching him do this
because you know Matt Murdock is such a
misery guts he's such a sad-sack that
it's really nice to see Charlie dykes
get to play somebody in you know lighter
more freewheeling a bit more up for
adventure then you know that Matt is so
he just lives in a fairly ordinary town
in England called wall and it's so named
because there is a wall that separates
the town from what looks like a field
there's a gap in the wall that's guarded
by a rather old guard and you know
people don't pass through the gap in the
wall except Tristan's father did once
upon time and now Tristan himself goes
on adventure on the other side of the
wall which basically takes them to an
entire different world basically a fairy
tale world for lack of a better term and
the reason Tristan goes there is because
he's trying to impress a local girl
named Victoria played by Sienna Miller
and
when they see a falling star he says
I'll go find you and bring you that star
to prove my love and it fell on the Osun
wolf that's where he goes and when he
gets there what he finds is not a lump
of rock what he finds instead is a woman
named Devane played by Claire Danes who
is in fact the fallen star and he then
goes about trying to bring her back to
show to Victoria she doesn't really like
that that's obviously tension between
the two of them there are additional
complications in the form of why the
star fell in the first place so boy I'm
going to weigh more detail on the plot
that I normally would but like I don't
know how well seen this movie is at this
point but anyways so in a wonderful
cameo by the late great Peter O'Toole
playing the dying king of of Stormhold
which is sort of the name of this realm
he has well when the film starts he has
four sons Sons left
it's very quickly brought down to three
and he's a little bit annoyed because he
originally had seven sons and
traditionally what happens in this
kingdom is however many sons there are
kill each other until there's only one
left and that one gets to be the heir
well King's Own is dying on his deathbed
and there's three left so that's a
problem this wasn't supposed to happen
so the way he decides to go ahead and
fix that is by taking the jewel off his
crown he throws it up until the sky
where it hits the star and both come
crashing down to earth and he tasks his
remaining sons to get the stone and
whoever gets the stone gets to be the
next king and so you've got these these
other forces trying to find the stone
that happens to be a notch ain't on the
chain around the veins neck and then
additional complication there is a which
played by Michelle Pfeiffer and she on
behalf of herself and her sisters is
looking for the
are to cut out her heart so they can eat
it and be young and beautiful again so
you basically have three parties
interested in the star interested in a
vein one is Tristan
then there's the witch and then there's
the princes so you've got all this going
on in this world that has magic and
unicorns and transformation of people
into animals or animals into people and
and soothsayers and pirates who capture
lightning from from live storms and sell
it on the black market and all this kind
of stuff is where all this is set and
that's your setting for your rollicking
fantasy adventure story now I I haven't
seen Stardust in a long time like I I
owned it so it was like it was nice to
be commissioned to watch it because like
I didn't have to I didn't have to
acquire it from somewhere else I didn't
have to rent it I didn't have to search
for it on-screen email like oh I'll go
downstairs and get off the shelf but I
haven't seen it in ages I can't remember
the last time I saw this movie so part
of me was a little nervous because you
know when you haven't seen something for
a while
particularly something that you know
contains things that you might be more
sensitive about now than you were when
you saw before and I'll get into detail
on that stuff a little bit later anyone
who's seen the movie probably knows what
I'm talking about but I'll sort of hold
that for a little bit stake a pin in
that we'll come back to it the movie is
a lot of fun and the actors all seem
like they're having an absolute blast
doing this Robert DeNiro plays the the
captain of the the ship for the for the
guys who like captured lightning Captain
Shakespeare who's who's another one of
the big differences from the book he's
pretty much a creation entirely of the
movie the Pirates capturing lightning
they do exist in the book for one page
literally like a stopover reference
thing to help Tristan and Vayne get from
point A to point B at one point and like
none of them are named and there's no
lingering there so this entire character
of Captain Shakespeare and his crew was
basically developed by Matthew Vaughn
and and the other people behind this
movie so that's another thing that's
pretty unique to this and he's obviously
having an absolute blast doing this for
me though I think the MVP is Michelle
Pfeiffer because not only is she clearly
having a lot of fun playing this I think
there's oh God you know I hate the word
I'm about to use because using this to
describe an actor is like it's so
frigging cliche but it's the one that
stuck in my head
I think there's something kind of brave
in her playing the Witch and again III
kind of I'm kind of mad at myself for
even saying that but what I mean by that
is um she and I mean more so now but
even at even at the time this came out
over ten years ago was at an age where
basically women don't get to play the
female romantic lead anymore and they
have to start playing the mothers the
and possibly the Crone's and things like
that but Michelle Pfeiffer still looked
great but also you could tell she was no
longer a young woman so I think there
was a bit of there was maybe bravery is
in the wrong way there was a bit of
thumbing her nose that the expectations
of Hollywood to take on this role where
she gets to at some points play it very
beautiful and Gore's and but like trying
to hold on to that is the entire point
of the character and every time she uses
magic she ages visibly until like
towards the end she looks awful and
Michelle Pfeiffer like really altering
her her physicality because you know
when she's young and vibrant she she's
physically you know vivacious and later
on like she's all hunched over and like
these slow movements you can practically
hear her bones creaking it's really
great some other people who are in this
I mean I made Charlie Cox again he is
very good he's very likable pretty much
immediately so he works very well
Harry cow
in this not like briefly but like just
as a jerk got an odd number of uh like
superheroes turn up in this it's
interesting um but we've also got Mark
Strong who's played Sinestro in a
superhero movie okay and he's gonna be
the villain this Shazam mark Strong has
played a lot of villains and he plays
one of the buddy plays the youngest of
the brothers he plays Septimus and this
is probably my favorite villain ish
because like a lot of these characters
are kind of like I don't know if you're
like a villain but you're certainly a
problem a year and yet because for what
is normal and villainous by the
standards of this world it's set in it's
a little weird but I think this is my
favorite intimidating villain style turn
from Mark Strong I really love him in
this part and again he feels like he's
getting to have a little bit more fun
here than he sometimes is I think
sometimes he he really is expected to be
like just the serious mm-hmm
you know and things like when he was in
the the Sherlock Holmes or honestly when
did they had him do Sinestro and it
wasn't even a villain in that one yet
and and some things like that but I
really do enjoy him quite a bit in this
and I think he does great work you have
also God Jason Fleming as pres premisis
who's the oldest brother they and we see
some others there's also there's a
really funny cameo for one into one of
the brothers who we see early on and I
don't want to spoil for that is if you
haven't seen the movie cuz it's quite
funny and there's there is a lot of
humor which again adds more towards the
swashbuckling adventures feel to the
movie that the book doesn't happen
because the book has a very literate
sensibilities which most of Neil
Gaiman's writing tends to have and and
actually I hold this up as a pretty good
example of the kinds of changes you need
to make to something to make it work
better in the medium you're now working
with because pretty much all the things
that they changed in terms of what was
removed
and the streamlining and what the
changes were in sort of a sub we're all
working towards making it work better as
a film because a lot of what works about
the book is stuff that doesn't translate
the the the literary flow of a fairy
tale because it is written anyway to
evoke a fairy tale doesn't have a direct
translation and one of the point the
book doesn't really have a climax it
just kind of goes until it ends until
you know it reaches its ending where you
get your little and then this happened
then that and at the end but it doesn't
have it certainly doesn't have a
cinematic climax it arguably doesn't
really have a climax at all and a movie
get kind of need one and they do
manufacture one that said the film could
still stand to be streamlined a little
bit more than it is the movie runs over
two hours and I think there's probably
about 20 minutes that could have been
saved from it particularly from the tail
end and actually from the climax and I
am gonna get into a little bit of spies
I'm not gonna go into heavy detail here
but I mean if you haven't already seen
it what I'm about to describe as far as
the climax goes you know has to do with
what's happening to the end if you know
everyone's looking for the star what am
I allowed to describe is not really
spoiler it's a set up you should
appreciate so we're in a situation where
all interested parties the surviving
Prince's the witch and Tristan are all
converging on a vein and it's actually
building really amazingly as they're all
all coming together and like boy this is
really gonna come to a head but it
doesn't what happens is a vein gets
kidnapped by one of the people involved
taken somewhere else and then the others
have to go to this other place and we
have to we have to build a new head of
steam for a climax and it's really kind
of odd it built to a very organic
natural climax and then stops it moves
the entire thing to a different location
and then
you try and pick up the momentum of the
climax again and it really does feel
like it loses steam a bit by doing that
I mean the the setting where everything
was originally converging was maybe a
little dull so I mean you just move that
somewhere else and half the climax
happen at the natural point which is
about 20 minutes before the thing ended
and there's other little things here and
there that could have been trimmed down
and and and things of that nature but
that's sort of the one major thing for
me but I I also don't want to harp too
much on complaints because this movie is
a lot of fun and I enjoy it a lot but I
am gonna get into a little bit more
details about a specific thing because
if you know me and you know the fact
that I am gender fluid and I care about
representation of gender fluidity and
cross-dressing
then yeah there's something else we got
to talk about here so if you haven't
seen it and it sounded interesting maybe
go watch it before I start to dive into
this and like ruin the fun for you so
let's talk about the sort of transgender
and then the cross-dressing characters
first there's bernhard who is a young
man turned first into a goat and then
turned into a young woman i don't want
to dwell on that because actually i
don't think there's anything
particularly problematic about it like
he's kind of impressed with his own
breasts when he has them but you know
who would it be and i don't see that as
any kind of representation because it
was a circumstance foisted onto him cuz
the witch did that to him and then he
just kind of goes along with what's
going on he's just trying to not get
killed but i don't find anything
particularly problematic or you know
exemplary as representation with him but
it would have been weird if I hadn't
acknowledged that so let's get to the
real thing
Captain Shakespeare played by Robert De
Niro is an effeminate man who cross
dresses and I was really nervous to
revisit this because I remember being
okay with it when I saw it but like I
said I'd like I'm a bit more sensitive
to this than I used to be since I've
started really examining the patterns
that I see for the most part this whole
end
character held up a lot better than I
expected I think a big part of what
helps is that well a couple of things
first of all he's hiding this from his
crew but he's actually very happy to
have someone to talk to who he doesn't
have to worry about his reputation with
so he has a vein and Tristan and he's
he's oh he's basically out to them and
that's kind of sweet and so that
immediately helps us at expect he's not
embarrassed he's not humiliated he's not
ashamed but he is concerned for his
reputation as a hard-nosed pirate and he
is afraid of the hit that that will take
and that his crew won't respect him so
he has what feels like a pretty
justified fear of how the world will
react to him but he himself has no shame
about who he is or how he lives so that
helps that's the first thing the other
thing is is that he's pretty competent
in number of areas not all of them it's
actually demonstrated that he can't
pilot his ship very well but he's a
pretty good swordsman he yo teaches
Tristan how to use a sword pretty well
he can captain this crew he he I mean he
knows he has skills he is competent so
it's not like he is you know faking
skill he just has this whole other set
of stuff about him that he doesn't let
his crew know and then of course we
later learn when his crew does find out
that they kind of always suspected and
are totally cool with it which is also
nice there is a little bit of a problem
for me though and that is the extended
scene of him in a dressed sort of
flouncing around in his closet in the
mirror and I kind of have two problems
with this the the big one is just how
long it goes on because the length of
time that this is happening really does
give the feel that we are meant to find
this inherently funny and that this is
something that I Hey look at the guy in
a dress
isn't that funny hahaha and in and of
itself the scene kind of does that
anyway but how long it goes on you
really does does make it feel that way
and then the other thing
is just the way that robert deniro plays
it and what I mean by that is if I were
to compare to say Tracy story from
accused which I reviewed not long ago
that performance from Sean Bean really
felt like he had done a ton of research
on how a crossdresser you know behaves
and would act and would feel whereas
Robert DeNiro just seems to have been
told
hey just mess around in the dress for a
bit and and while it looks like he's
very much having fun nothing about it
reads to me as having an understanding
of what a man who wears a dress finds
appealing about that so when he's you
know looking you know with this feather
thing fan at himself I'm like hey yeah I
don't know it just it's just a little
crap it's not offensive it doesn't
offend me it just makes me go oh you
didn't need it so it doesn't ruin it but
there are those little moments that I
kind of could have done without but for
the most part I was surprised that I I
still feel comfortable saying I like
this character so that is Stardust like
I said if you haven't seen it I do
recommend it if you ever read the book I
recommend the book just be aware if
you've already seen the movie
significant difference mainly in tone
also with ending but you know the
fundamental the way things end like
situationally is the same it's just
there wasn't a climax in the book really
but other than that yeah that'll wrap it
up this was a patreon sponsored review
which means I have a patreon link down
below a whole bunch of other stuff
besides buttons links give them a look
click on them there's all kinds of links
down there check them out or don't cuz
uh at the end of the day folks you're
the council I just run the meetings
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]